among the reasons that I heard for
people wanting to vote for brexit were
well it's nice to have a change and well
I preferred the old blue Passport to the
European purple Passport these are the
kinds of reasons people were giving for
voting for brexit
the day after the referendum the most
googled question in Britain was what is
the European Union during the brexit
campaign one of the leading politicians
favouring brexit Michael Gove said to
the British people you are the experts
you don't trust experts you are the
experts now so ordinary people who have
absolutely no no knowledge of economics
or politics or history decided on a 50%
majority to vote Britain out of the
European market which was a out of the
European community which was a very very
complicated detailed ramified structure
that had been built up over decades and
so at one stroke the the British people
who had no knowledge no expertise were
allowed were given the opportunity by a
reckless David Cameron to vote us out
and they did by a very narrow margin
this count of everybody being an expert
all opinions being equally valid is I
think dangerous and most unfortunate of
course I have been accused of being an
elitist because of this and yes I mean
when you're about to have an operation
you want an elite surgeon to do the to
cut you open you want an elite
anesthetist to put you under when you're
about to fly what an elite pilot to fly
you when you're about to leave a
federation of states which has been
built up over decades you want an elite
economist or politician or historian to
advise you on it you don't want to take
the the view of just any old man in the
street or woman in the street
I pronounced myself profoundly
ill-equipped to vote on the referendum
about brexit I was ill-equipped so with
a vast majority of the British people in
look ill-equipped in that sense I think
that elitist should stop being a dirty
word and we should start to respect
elites in whatever field we're talking
about we want elite musicians to play in
our orchestras etc I think it's bad
enough to ask non experts like me to
vote and direct referendums winner when
we are also being fed false information
war is deliberately false information I
mean in the the Trump administration is
actually lying every day and and more as
proud of it in Britain the brexit
campaign had a bus you may read about
this they had a bus which had a great
big slogan on that on the side which
said that every day every week I think
it was some gigantic Sun was being paid
to the into the European Union which
would be if we left the if we left
Europe would be available for the
National Health now that was a admitted
lie that seemed quite simply false and
many people were probably swayed by that
consideration to vote to leave the
European Union so no I do I do think we
need to stick to democracy as it is but
I think it's a representative democracy
that we have in Britain we have a
parliamentary democracy where we don't
actually vote normally we don't vote on
actual issues we vote members of
parliament members of parliament then go
to the House of Commons and then they
vote on our behalf and we have cabinet
government where the cabinet gets advice
from civil servants who are expert so
now I'm not advocating that II you know
people with PhDs should get to vote so
in anything light like that I mean I
don't want it to be elitist to quite
that extent so let's go for
representative democracy but not
referendum democracy I mean I think it's
worth adding that the the precedent for
not
everybody having the same vote same
weighted vote is already
well-established in the United States
when you think about voting for the
United States Senate where every state
gets two senators what that means is
that a citizen of Wyoming has I think
equivalent of sixty votes compared to a
citizen of California because if you
look at the the actual relative
population sizes of Wyoming and
California so in a way that pass has
already been sold that we already see
gross inequality 760 fold inequalities
in the in the weight and the Senate of
course is very important because the
Senate does not only take hugely
important decisions but also ratifies
presidential nominees for the Supreme
Court and that could be the most
important single thing that a president
ever does is appoint members to the
Supreme Court because they go on and on
for decades in say in some cases after
the president has gone
you